Okay, everybody. We don't have 10 pennies at 10 minutes past.
the hour
I was hoping to show you an example with.
Show you RC examples with the exercises
what we have.
But you know sometimes technical failures are
on avoidable now the less.
I think you know some of us shared our
interest in having.
a workshops
dedicated exclusively to
our studio and our programming.
And I think we will definitely have one.
I mean that was a plan. Anyway, we would do three work.
We would have three sessions.
in this series and then
going forward with that we would have had workshops dedicated to
certain to like specific topics in our
study would be among them.
But I will definitely up like share the
scripts with you.
with documentation
and then we will revisit that we will definitely
by the way revisit these scripts for day
three because
on day through like I said, we will continue talking
about
Random variables and probably distributions. We
will then talk about new topics like Point estimation.
or estimation in general and we'll
talk about
estimating points estimating confidence intervals, which
will be important because
we are going to
Work our way towards hypothesis testing and regression analysis two
ways two important ways.
for
conducting a statistical study. So everything we covered.
Day one day two.
Will be Revisited on day three.
culminating in a comprehensive
Statistical study so we will do our studio.
We will do more examples more exercises.
and
hopefully
we will be.
Probably like we will be able to complete all
of that in a better place.
But I will I will share the details for day
three and the preparations would
have to make for that day on Slack.
So if you're not on slack yet, please go ahead and join us
join snack so you don't miss out on that.
curriculum information
and that's it for today everybody. I want
to thank you for
joining us.
I want you all to enjoy the rest of your day.
Stay tuned for day three.
This video of course will be shared.
this week
the edited version of this video will be shipped this week.
including the slides
the updated reader
and
the opioid Scripts
the big number application will be shared.
Hopefully by the weekend.
So, thank you everybody and I will see you
all later. Bye.